[Musik]
ich bin ein rechtskräftig verurteilter
mörder
so formal korrekt weil der auffassung
waren dass irgendeiner und am besten ich
eingesperrt werden soll
[Musik]
benedikt ort genannt benze spricht da
über sich selbst 16 jahre knast sitzt er
in der jva stadelheim ab in dieser
episode von tatort deutschland machen
wir uns gemeinsam ein bild davon ob bei
diesem aufsehenerregenden fall am ende
ein unschuldiger hinter gitter wanderte
ich bin sky dumont und freue mich dass
er wieder dabei seit heute der parkhaus
mord
[Musik]
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
[Musik]
mein name ist laura gehrmann ich arbeite
seit mehr als zehn jahren für bild und
habe natürlich viel mit mord prozessen
und auch anderen fällen vor gericht zu
tun die immer wahnsinnig spannend sind
und einer dieser fälle ist der fall von
charlotte böhringer
reporterin laura gehrmann blättert durch
die archivierten artikel der bild am 15
mai 2006 mit in münchen die als parkhaus
millionärin bezeichnete charlotte
böhringer eiskalt und mit 24
hammerschlägen in ihrer wohnung ermordet
der verdacht der ermittlungsbehörden
fällt auf den neffen der ermordeten auf
benedikt todd
94 tage dauerte indizienprozess im
anschluss wird benedikt ort wegen mordes
verurteilt wegen der schwere seiner tat
wird er bis 2028 im gefängnis bleiben
aber es gibt keine stichhaltigen beweise
für seine tat und bis heute beteuert
benedikt benze tod seine unschuld
die bild reporterin ist vom deutschen
rechtssystem überzeugt sie kann sich
nicht vorstellen dass ein mensch auf
basis von indizien vielleicht sogar
unschuldig im gefängnis sitzt es lässt
ihr keine ruhe es ist boarding für ihren
flug berlin münchen
in münchen wird sie heute mit denen am
prozess beteiligten menschen und dem
vermeintlichen täter sprechen
[Musik]
termin nummer eins für die reporterin
münchen innenstadt der fachanwalt für
strafrecht peter witting der verteidiger
von bands sind tot der rechtsanwalt
arbeitet seit 38 jahren als
strafverteidiger er ringt sichtlich um
fassung
56 begangen worden seien in der zeit um
18.19 uhr 1930 dance pop soll es in der
parkgarage
angekommen sein er muss nach auffassung
der ermittlungsbehörden handschuhe
getragen haben er muss also präpariert
gewesen sein für einen anschlag
gleichsam gegen seine tante
er war bewaffnet mit einem unbekannten
gegenstand
er soll dann vor der eingangstür der
wohnung charlotte böhringer gewartet
haben wohl wissen dass sie gegen 19 uhr
30 üblicherweise am montag zwar wohnt
hat
zum stammtisch im tal geht und charlotte
böhringer war im begriff die wohnung zu
verlassen so die these und benedikt hat
dann 24 mal auf sein opfer eingeschlagen
bis sie am ende eines kleinen fluss also
vom eingang licht und wohnungs inneres
zu liegen kommt und dort versteckt ich
war das war immer
meine überzeugung so weit waren als
verteidiger überzeugt sein kann und darf
dass ihr nicht enthält das ist deutlich
die bild reporterin bedankt sich und
macht sich auf den weg zum münchner büro
ihrer zeitung dort erwartet sie axel
petermann petermann war polizeibeamter
zuletzt stellvertretender leiter der
mordkommission in bremen mittlerweile
ist er bekannt als bestsellerautor und
profiler er wird in vielen fällen als
experte zu rate gezogen die eltern und
der bruder von ben said haben sich an
ihn gewandt und ihn gebeten sich die
akten des falls noch einmal genauer
anzusehen ich bin der auffassung dass
mir die spuren einer tat in ganz ganz
viel über den ablauf des verbrechens
berichten
in der nähe des münchner stadtzentrums
befindet sich das iza parkhaus das
ehemalige böhringer parkhaus das ist ein
schlichtes fünfgeschossiges gebäude
unscheinbar alterslos aber in der
obersten etage befindet sich noch heute
das penthouse von charlotte böhringer im
mordopfer
reporterin und profiler betreten
gemeinsam die wohnung
riesige räume mit teilweise
kuppelförmigen decke alles wird
herrschaftlich modern und vielleicht ein
wenig zu grell der boden heller marmor
und die vielen fenster sorgen für
lichtdurchflutete zimmer hier hat frau
böhringer zum tatzeitpunkt als single
gewohnt auf einem großen tisch im
wohnzimmer breiten laura gehrmann und
der ex-polizist tatort fotos aus auf
einem ist die frauenleiche in einer
riesigen blutlache zu sehen also ich bin
zunächst erstmal davon ausgegangen dass
der gutachter recht hatte mit seiner
angabe dass der täter handschuhe
getragen hatte und es fängt damit an
dass gesagt wurde an der eingangstür das
kann man hier auf diesem foto sonst
schon gesehen dass die eingangstür hier
oben ist der spion habe sich der abdruck
eines handschuhs befunden und dieser
abdruck ist dann gesichert worden und
das ist jetzt hier das bild es vom
vermeintlichen handschuhe trug wenn man
sich das aber sehr genau anschaut dann
wird man sehen das ist doch recht um
regelmäßige kontrollen sind manche so
grossmann hilfen klein manche sind lang
gezogen das war so der erste zweifel den
ich hatte dass ich dachte wenn ich das
so unregelmäßig muss es überhaupt ein
handschuh sein und dann wurde eine
zweite spur für die eines handschuhs
gehalten und dann habe ich mir die dann
angeguckt und vergrößert das hat mich
nicht überzeugt und deswegen habe ich
mir sachverständigen gesucht die eben
halt sich mit vielen bezirken spuren
auseinandersetzen und die haben dann
gesagt es ist ein fingerabdruck besser
gesagt hier ist wahrscheinlich der
abdruck einer an kannte die reporterin
hakt nach
für das gericht war sehr sehr wichtig es
behauptete der täter sei vorbereitet
gewesen und diese handschuhe abdruck der
wahl letztendlich entscheidend dass er
die besondere schwere der schuld
zugesprochen bekam
kann das sein ein handschuh abdruck ist
die grundlage für den längsten
indizienprozess münchen denn erst am 12
august 2008 wird das urteil gegen benze
tod gesprochen schuldig laura gehrmann
denkt nach die aussagen von verteidiger
witting und profiler petermann machen
sie skeptisch die journalistin muss nun
auch die andere seite hören sie besucht
rechtsanwalt dr alexander stevens um
sich die sichtweise der anklage
schildern zu lassen stevens war zur zeit
des prozesses rechtsanwaltsanwärter bei
der staatsanwaltschaft münchen mit dem
parkhaus mortka nicht in berührung weil
ich zur zeit der verhandlung des parkes
mannes bei der staatsanwaltschaft meine
wahl station gemacht hat er natürlich
kriegt man dann auch das ein oder andere
mit was man vielleicht als
außenstehender nicht mitbekommen hätte
und damit war das interesse geweckt und
jahre später habe ich ein buch
geschrieben bei dem es um perfekte morde
gehen und deswegen habe ich mich also
diese in diesem fall angenommen da sehr
sehr tiefgreifend recherchiert urteil
natürlich gelesen auch akten gelesen und
dann mir dann ein eigenes bild gemacht
und diese geschichte zu papier gebracht
auf die frage ob benedikt ben said
schuldig ist antwortet dr stevens sehr
bestimmt also dass er zu recht hinter
gittern sitzt davon bin ich zu 100
prozent definitiv überzeugt doch damit
alleine gibt sich bild reporterin
gehrmann nicht zufrieden sie will wissen
wie die polizei beim verhör von bands
hervorgegangen ist zu dem zeitpunkt
hatte die münchner mordkommission
nachweislich es sich fortgebildet in den
usa zu einer gewissen methode der
sogenannten geriet methode und die macht
also folgendes da gibt es nicht nur den
good cop und im bett kopf diese methode
kennt man ja alle eine schreit und ist
dann für den
beschuldigten für den betroffenen dann
diese aggressive person vor der angst
hat und der andere ist oder nette der
kumpel zu dem man sich dann irgendwie
hingezogen fühlt und sich dann
gegebenenfalls öffnet zur theorie bei
der methode ist es noch eine ganze ecke
krasser und das einfach mal ganz kurz
übers knie zu brechen
versucht man da den leuten letztlich die
parteien zu reden indem man sie mürbe
macht die werden über stunden lang
vernommen und denen werden dann auch
dinge in aussicht gestellt die wenn sie
die taten einräumen niemals zu treffen
werden dann werden alternativen
vorgegeben damit gesagt mehr du warst
doch da und da aber du hast du doch
eigentlich gar nichts schlechtes gedacht
also das messer in die hand genommen
hast du wolltest doch damit eigentlich
nur irgendwie schnitzen oder irgendwas
geben ihm alternativen vor die er dann
aufnimmt und wenn er dann oft wissen sie
sie haben den täter und dann gehen sie
halt richtig hart mit dem ins gefecht
dass man eben letztlich eingeständnis
dass es das eigentliche ziel der wied
methode dann aus der nase gezogen hätte
das gibt es ja eben nicht aber sah sich
wohl genötigt und ich finde das wort
genötigt passt auch ganz gut dinge zu
sagen und sich dadurch
eklatante widersprüche zu verstricken
aus denen es mal rauskommen nach dieser
aussage zu den vernehmungsmethoden der
ermittler muss die bild reporterin mit
der entscheidenden personen sprechen sie
wird ben zu treffen und begibt sich
dafür auf eine zweistündige fahrt von
münchen zur jva straubing
mit der erlaubnis für das interview
trifft sie den verurteilten altert und
hager sitzt er vorher seine grau blauen
augen zeigen keine wut aber auch keine
freude laura gehrmann setzt sich ihm
gegenüber und tänze beginnt zu erzählen
was kurz nach seiner verhaftung geschah
ich dachte ja tatsächlich vielleicht
dennoch alten stunde lang werde ich
wieder entlassen es sind ja so viel
leben widersprüche evozieren wurden
natürlich natürlich habe ich die bösen
willen gesehen aber jedem gefällt mir
gedacht es kann eigentlich kann das
nicht sein weil das sind doch gute und
dass jeder widerspruch der mir dann
vorgeworfen wurde das war das war
evozieren seitens der mitglieder haben
sowas nicht kapiert oder sie wollten was
nicht kapieren und wann gabs
themenkreise wo ich dann absichtlich
verwirrend werden sollte wären wir die
idee was jetzt einfällt kombination
unseres tresors und ich sollte jetzt
dann halt den tresor fiktiv dann öffnen
oder geistig öffnen und dann ging es
darum wie viele umdrehungen dort bis
wohin stopp zurück ich meine
interessiert ist natürlich dann als
scharfrichter an konzentriere mich
schneller das muss schneller gehen
schneller noch mal von vorne schnell
allein das war nicht wichtig noch mal
was heißt hier das war nicht wichtig und
sie sind irgendwann einmal als instanz
ist das tatsächlich so weitermachen soll
dann mit und dann hoffen sie okay jetzt
ist es vorbei sein nein es stimmt nicht
dass sollen jedoch bestimmt ich kann
meinen tresor nicht ihr und was tut das
im übrigen zur sache das müsste sich
schon als überlastet was wir fragen was
sind also kleinigkeiten die die uhrzeit
war schon beschlossene sache der dort
verlässt dieses gebäude wieder also für
die war das klar ist noch nicht klar na
ja und das hat sich dann ein immer
empfehlen hochgeschaukelt bis ich dann
gesagt habe mit dem rede ich nicht mehr
also ich gehe jetzt also ich war dann
tatsächlich auch schon aufgestanden er
genauso im moment kommt von der
seitentür in latein und also der wahl
schon sehr viele er mich sehr
freundschaftlich und sehr sehr liebevoll
wieder wieder beruhigt und
alles
und ich soll doch bitte schön bisschen
nach seinen kollegen gegen gegenüber es
auch übernächtigten also wie gesagt dass
er es dann natürlich schon sehr
geschickt gemacht
details verschiedene stränge miteinander
verwendet wurden und es kann natürlich
kein eindeutiges ergebnis dann raus und
ich habe versucht wieder die steine zu
entwirren haben gesagt das war neben tag
das waren neben tag wunder dass während
wieder andere ergebnisse haben
das heißt gescheitert in ihr schmeißt
alles in einem druck von einer kundin
ist aber kein wunder denn ideen banane
weil es zwei tage nicht geschlafen aber
wenn ich versuche mich zu konzentrieren
nach dieser prozedur wird dem jungen
mann verkündet dass er nun eigentlich
erst festgenommen ist
es war nicht mehr so eine überraschung
weil ich jetzt ja eigentlich schon
wissen müssen die stunden vorher
ich habe das irgendwie nicht aus mir
raus gebracht
trotzdem glauben zu schenken dass ich da
sitze um zu helfen
manchmal auch psychisch dann doch in
einer ausnahmesituation also zwei tage
kaum geschlafen kaum gegessen nicht mehr
sind sie ganz erfahrenen leuten
gegenüber dieses kreuz legen wollen die
journalistin ist auf der rückfahrt nach
münchen nachdenklich und im zweifel wie
sie die so gegensätzlichen aussagen
einordnen soll sie will den fall noch
besser verstehen dazu gehört es mehr
über das opfer zu erfahren wie hat
charlotte böhringer gelebt wie war ihre
beziehung zu ihrem neffen benzel dafür
trifft sie sich mit brigitte klein einer
guten freundin der ermordeten
geschäftsfrau
gemeinsam stehen sie vor der pizzeria
lago di garda die sich direkt neben dem
parkhaus befindet
[Musik]
ein zwei mal hat sie das gemacht aber
da war sie auch zu nervös sie wollte das
perfekt machen dass sie hat dann lieber
in die kneipe eingeladen das war ja
angenehmer als bei sich zu hause okay
aber die berichterstattung hatte das
mordopfer charlotte böhringer auch als
sehr gesellig und trinkfreudig
bezeichnet ja das würde ich so
bestätigen also gut und gerne einen
gebechert schickeria würde ich sagen
sie sah sehr gut aus und es wurde
zeitung berichtet darüber mit fotos sind
und bussi bussi sie hat dieses leben
sehr genossen sind venedig haben wir
öfter mal kennengelernt da hat sie öfter
begleitet und er war auch ihr lieblings
neffe später kamen ja dann im laufe der
zeit dass das der netze verdächtigt
wurde und wir waren erst mal völlig
fassungslos natürlich gab es auch leute
die gesagt haben der arme kerl wurde von
ihr hin und her geschickt und muss die
jura studieren und wollte das nicht und
die freundin wurde nicht akzeptiert
möglicherweise hat sie ja auch auf den
geldhahn gesessen also die spekulation
da haben doch einige angetreten die sie
auch kannten weil
man befürchtet hat dass auf seine
bedürfnisse und seine wünsche von ihrer
seite möglicherweise zu wenig rücksicht
genommen wird die reporterin hörte in
den aufnahmen aus der jva nach was benze
dazu gesagt hat hätte er überhaupt einen
grund gehabt seine tante zu ermorden
komplex also meine karte war ja die
hochkomplexe frau wenn sie fröhlich war
war sie vielleicht zu fröhlich für die
begriffe haben dann erneute minze
traurig war also dann auch gleich
melancholisch wenn sie gemacht hat hat
sie lieb tanzen
nicht gemacht hat sollte hast alles in
ordnung oder einschätzbar für mich ich
meine ich also mein ganzes leben lang
gekannt also von von kleinen
kindesbeinen an um also meine tante wird
ja jetzt leider fast durchgehend negativ
dargestellt was ja nicht so ist ich
meine es halt dann das was vielleicht
hängen bleibt bei denen diese nicht
gekannt haben also zunächst mal meine
tante eine sehr liebende und großzügige
frau und sie hat halt aber auch
ansprüche gestellt ja und sie hat
ihre vorstellungen nicht
erfüllt wurden auch kein blatt vorm mund
genommen benedikt nimmt sie in schutz
vor den negativen darstellungen in der
presse die reporterin vermutet kalkül
will er betonen dass er gar keinen grund
hatte so eine tat zu begehen
charlotte böhringer war erbin und
geschäftsfrau zu der das boehringer
parkhaus samt tankstelle und werkstatt
gehörte die witwe hatte zur zeit der tat
ihre beiden neffen angestellt menze als
assistent der geschäftsführung und
seinen bruder mate als schichtleiter und
den trifft die bild reporterin in genau
dem parkhaus über dem der mord geschah
an dem tag hatte ich spätschicht beginnt
um 15.45 ich war kurz davor da die
mitarbeiter der frühschicht haben gesagt
dass sie meine tante nicht erreicht
haben also der sich den ganzen tag nicht
gerührt nun wir wussten nicht wo sie ist
oder warum sie nicht da ist ich kann
mich noch daran erinnern ich habe
sozusagen seinem handy angerufen hier
von der tür und da habe auch das klingen
auf der anderen seite gehört die unruhe
war immer größer später war oben auf dem
dach welcher gedacht haben vielleicht
hat sie hinten weil der waschküche
fenster offen gelassen zum lüften dass
man vielleicht auch in die wohnung rein
kommt man
alle fenster zu und es war auch nichts
zu sehen ja ich war ja auch perplex mein
bruder hat sich übergeben ich wusste ja
auch gar nicht ob es einen mord oder ein
unfall passen die treppe vielleicht
heruntergestürzt ist in unzähligen
zeitungsartikeln die über die
abscheuliche tat veröffentlicht wurden
waren immer wieder zweifel an der schuld
von benze tod geäußert worden
ein wichtiger punkt für den schuldspruch
war der todeszeitpunkt profiler axel
petermann misstraut der korrekten
bestimmung der todeszeit der mageninhalt
eine möglichkeit einzuschätzen wann
jemand gestorben ist das gericht war
davon überzeugt dass die rechtsmediziner
mit ihren berechnungen zum mageninhalt
recht hatten in dem sie meinten
charlotte böhringer seien gegen 8 10 uhr
15 getötet worden wir sind hier weil
charlotte böhringer kokskohle die im
lago di garda gewesen ist man hat in
ihrem wagen sagte keller speise gefunden
und die menge hat man mit 100 gramm
gemessen und diese menge bedeutet dass
sie bereits viertel des gerichts bereits
verdaut hatte und ging davon aus dass
400 kommunen gewesen sein sollen die
bild reporterin wirft ein dass charlotte
böhringer eventuell weniger gegessen
haben könnte richtig charlotte böhringer
so hieß es sei eine sehr
körperbewusste frau gewesen die auf ihre
figur beachtet hat die appetitzügler
einnahmen also nochmal zur pizzeria lago
di garda der betreiber ist bereit zwei
unterschiedlich große portionen des
nudelgericht zu servieren dass charlotte
böhringer als letzte mahlzeit zu sich
genommen haben soll axel petermann
kommentiert die beiden unterschiedlichen
portionen nun haben wir zwei portionen
hier eine große eine kleine das gericht
hatte angenommen dass die portion so
groß gewesen ist viermal
entspricht das was charlotte böhringer
gegessen hat die
und das werde zu viel
na so was
und genau dann kam er nicht in frage
also man muss sagen es lässt sich
überhaupt nicht feststellen beim salat
und boehringer gestorben ist um ein
fazit ist dass viele der vom gericht
angeführten indizien nicht schließlich
finden und aus diesem grunde hätte
benedikt nie verurteilt werden dürfen
die bild reporterin sitzt wieder im büro
von verteidiger witting
abgeschlossen
haben sie denn das gefühl dass er
sämtliche spuren verfolgt wurden dass
die ermittlungen
es ist von anfang an nur einseitig
ermittelt worden nur gegen benedikt ab
und zwar ab mindestens ab dem zeitpunkt
seiner festnahme am 16.5 abends um 19
uhr
da waren hiermit versichere sie haben
den richtigen und es ging nur um gehen
und nichts anderes
die reporterin scrollt wieder durch ihre
aufnahmen mit bands wie hatte eigentlich
den tag des mordes erlebt
also müsste der 15.15 2006 gewesen sein
ich war in der früh
zu hause geblieben
weil ich eine grippe
ausgebildet haben
ich war den ganzen tag nicht im geschäft
an diesem montag jedenfalls ist meine
verlobte dann
gegen fünf ist sie gegangen und ist dann
abends gegen 22 oder 23 30
dann kam der
dienstag war ein normaler tag also ich
war dann auch schon
intern was ich war bald werde dann ganz
normal im geschäft und so genanntes büro
gefahren als wir unsere tante nicht
erreicht haben
und mein bruder oder wo der boden oder
auch unsere mitarbeiter also dass das
das war als schlecht für immer zum
gleichen kaste also wir haben zum
beispiel auch irgend etwas gebraucht ich
hätte halt sondern von meiner tag der
auch ausgelaugt für die abrechnung ja
wir haben sie nicht erreicht das war
jetzt noch keinen keinen keine anders
führen mit dem restaurant weil so etwas
regelmäßig vorgekommen es dass er
spontan band gefahren das jetzt nicht
länger aber durchaus wir haben oder halt
vielleicht irgendwann längere nacht
gehabt wenn um die uhrzeit einfach noch
nicht dran gehen möchte punkt fertig gut
dann auch mal anderen ist und da war es
tatsächlich schon
also spielt danach den tag um mein
bruder dann festgestellt an der tür
brechen also das handy angerufen dass
das handy tatsächlich aus der aus der
wohnung durch klänge da war es wieder
das handy klingeln hören das war dann
schon außergewöhnlich und das war dann
das war dann der hintergrund wurde die
die ursache dafür dass wir gesagt haben
sollen jetzt muss mal angehen und weil
ich einen schlüssel 100 gewann zum
schlüssel zur wohnung gehabt habt es ist
wieder einen einer der geschäftsführer
gebeten vorbeizukommen der den schlüssel
hatte und immer gehe ich dann
letztendlich um
kurz nach sieben dann in die wohnung
gegangen
das war auf alle fälle bemerkenswert
hält also das ist ja dann ein gewand auf
der festplatte
wir sind ziemlich herr lagen augen der
auch kurz davor gestrichen wurden der
hell gestrichen wurde helga marmorboden
also
meine tante lag da
in einer riesigen blutlache und alles
war voll mit blut ich bin tatsächlich
jetzt noch nicht davon ausgegangen dass
die tour zu ende ist erst einmal
irgendwie auch irgendwie scheiße jetzt
setzen wir die treppe die haut weil das
war halt auch das ins wahre liebe
schlachthaus anders kann ich es nicht
sagen also zumindest für meine erfahrung
für mich war es halt extrem und ich oder
es kann aus ich weiß es nicht mehr genau
jedenfalls bin ich angestoßen wurden von
von dem geschäftsführer schau mal nach
dem puls daran kann ich mich noch
erinnern und dann bin ich hin habe mich
hingekniet und ich bin aber nicht einmal
dazu gekommen dass ich da irgendwie nach
dem puls tatsächlich suchen als ich
angefasst habe habe ich gemerkt ist es
natürlich kalt stellen das nicht nicht
wie plastik
also da hat offensichtlich das leben
gefüllt es bleibt am ende nur eine frage
die nach dem motiv der staatsanwalt gibt
der reporterin bei ihrem besuch zu
protokoll er hat ein motiv das
erstklassige gar nicht sein könnte die
problematik dass seine tante ihn
regelrecht geschafft hatte er war nicht
mehr der stellvertretende
geschäftsführer oder assistent der
geschäftsführung nein es gab jetzt einen
neuen mann hat ihm sogar den schlüssel
weggenommen eine größere degradierung
gibt es da gar nicht aber und jetzt
kommt der der mary bigpoint wenn sie
trotz hatte über jahre hinweg
behauptet jura zu studieren und nicht
nur das sondern auch an jura examen
abgelegt zu haben er hatte sogar ein
weißwurstfrühstück ausgerichtet um das
ganze zu feiern das alles hat nicht
gestimmt es gab so ein jurastudium das
hat er aber abgebrochen das war aber
eiserne bedingung der tante für ihn
irgendwann mal die geschicke dieser park
dieses parkhauses leiten zu dürfen dass
haben sehr sehr viele zeugen genauso
ausgesagt waren wir noch ein streit der
sehr unmittelbar vor der tat
stattgefunden haben soll den wenn sie
dort aber zunächst in seiner vernehmung
verschweigt und dann aber auch in eine
weitere vernehmung viel weiter
vordatiert auch das ist schon sehr
merkwürdig raum tut er das warum es ab
spricht er nicht die wahrheit worum ging
es bei dem streit
bei dem streit ging es wohl um irgend
etwas profanes mit den reifen das sind
nicht richtig aufgeräumt waren wie auch
immer aber die tante auch sehr cool er
schwul hat ihn da also sehr zu minder
gemacht und auch so zumindest nach den
feststellungen des gerichts urteils des
rufes wiesen und gesagt er solle
gekommen
also ein solches motiv bünde gleich
findet man selten und dann natürlich
die tatsache dass der ein millionen erbe
auf ihn warten würde wir reden ja hier
müsst von kleinigkeiten
und alle seine probleme und sorgen wenn
mit einem male mit dem tod der tante weg
gewesen ich habe keine zweifel dass
hat benze gelogen was eine tat im affekt
der wut auf seine tante
hatte charlotte böhringer von dem
lügengespinst ihres lieblings neffen
gewusst der bruder des verurteilten
mörders hat dazu eine ganz eigene
meinung ganz klar ich bin ja auch hier
gewesen und also ich hätte ja nicht
erfahren müssen und wie alles drum herum
konstruiert wurde zeitfenster ich war ja
vor ort ich war ja luftlinie hier von
stadtwerken oder vier stockwerke tiefer
da hätten sie mich genauso rausnehmen
können wahrscheinlich haben sie heute
angesagt na ja da hat es einen streit
gegeben mit eingelagerten reifen und
dann haben sie dann gesagt das ist das
ist ja die haben sich gestritten in der
familie und dann haben die natürlich in
ihrem kommissar mord handbuch auf seite
28 familienangehörige des vereins streit
auf den grund
und dann wird alles dann negiert meine
mutter ja auch gesagt dass er nicht mehr
studieren das ist unsere tante gewusst
hat das ist auch ein prozess geklärt
worden ich meine die besten freundinnen
und der steuerberater haben ja auch
ausgesagt dass er nicht studiert hat und
im urteil steht drinnen charlotte
böhringer als bis zuletzt davon
ausgegangen hätte sein studium
erfolgreich beendet da sagt er zeige
dass und mode versand gehören
boarding flug münchen hamburg blaue
gehrmann reicht das gehörte nicht um
sich ein abschließendes gesamtbild zu
machen ich bin
dafür zuständig in dem fall dass
widerrufen haben wir verfahren ins
rollen zu bringen gerhard strate ist ein
spezialist für solche aussichtslosen
fälle und hat als einer der wenigen
überhaupt in der deutschen
rechtsgeschichte ist und ein paar mal
geschafft so wiederaufnahmeverfahren
erfolgreich durchzusetzen
zahlungshöhe montag laura wir haben
hallo das ist ungewöhnlich an den fall
ist deshalb schon ich will nicht sagen
ungewöhnlich wohl aber
zeichnet er sich dadurch aus dass er
wirklich
weise ins feld führt also das urteil
indizien zusammengestellt die alle jeder
für sich nicht unbedingt tragfähig
werden
insgesamt aber meinte damals das gericht
in der gesamtschau es würde dass
ausreichend um klar zu erklären dass
bachelot der täter ist der regel sind
die sind kapitalverbrechen die
infizieren zumindest an ein oder zwei
punkte immer doch von großer
eindeutigkeit das ist bei diesem fall
nicht also jedes indiz dass hier auf
menschen trotz hinweisen soll ist für
sich genommen relativ neutral da spricht
auch das gericht selber annehmen
schriftlichen urteilsgründen aber zum
schluss heißt es dann doch in der
gesamtschau sei es eindeutig und wünsche
dort sei der täter
warum sollte der fall ihrer meinung nach
wieder aufgeräumt werden
ich hatte mich hierbei konzentriert auf
zwei spuren die in der gesamtschau der
indizien von großer bedeutung sein
sollen nämlich zwei dna spuren an einem
briefumschlag in dem sich das testament
befand und des weiteren eine spur der
rückseite der jacke die brauchen ja an
dem tage getragen hat diese beiden
spuren sind nicht eindeutig zuzuordnen
es gibt mehrere spuren gebe vor allem
aus der familie die auch in betracht
kommen diese spuren müssen auch nicht am
tag tage angebracht haben sein
insgesamt plädiere ich in dem teil
meines wiederaufnahme antrages dafür
dass diese spuren auch nicht hätten
verwertet werden dürfen das führt laura
gehrmann zu ihrer abschließenden frage
die reporterin fliegt zurück nach berlin
sie muss weiter recherchieren erst dann
wird es in ihrem kopf ruhe geben wenn
dieser mann seit 16 jahren unschuldig im
gefängnis sitzt muss etwas getan werden
ist er schuldig dann können die
angehörigen des opfers und auch des
vermeintlichen täters damit abschließen
und die erinnern an charlotte böhringer
ruhe vor weiteren spekulationen finden
schön dass wir in dieser folge von
tatort deutschland dabei war ich hoffe
wir hören uns bald wieder sky dumont
[Musik]
ich bin von süd nach nord gereister
weggefährten von dem benedikt öfb
getroffen habe seine anwälte getroffen
aber auch menschen die damals in der
staatsanwaltschaft tätig waren und habe
wahnsinnig viele eindrücke gesammelt
die frage die sich mir stellt ist
natürlich ist er schuldig oder ist ja
nicht schuldig weil die werden wir nie
beantworten kann die werde ich auch nie
beantworten können die frage ist das
urteil so gerecht wie es gefällt wurde
und hätte es jemals so gefällt werden
durch muss natürlich eine andere und da
kann ich jetzt nach meinen recherchen
und nach meinen gesprächen sagen dass es
auf jeden zweifel daran gibt waren die
indizien wirklich ausreichend um ihn für
schuldig zu befinden und da kann man auf
jeden fall zweifel daran haben und auch
sagen dass die indizien nicht so
eindeutig waren das da ist eine
grundlage dafür war ihn so lange hinter
gittern zu packen
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios projektleitung
simonet herbrand
produktion fabian schaeffler
drehbuch dieter roas
bildredaktion laura gehrmann und stefan
metzen band
wo ist es so dass das kind haus der
ermordeten charlotte böhringer immer
noch fast so aussieht wie vor 16 jahren
bis reporterinnen laura gehrmann war da
sie ist mit dem profiler axel petermann
den spuren nachgegangen in folge 13 von
true story erzählt sie davon und von
ihrem besuch bei benedikt ort im
gefängnis ich bin julia sommerfeld in
meinem podcast history hört ihr die
spannendsten geschichten von reportern
bei axel springer und wie sie entstanden
sind hört doch mal rein